[Music]
Kawai nia rai me is a very special
festival held once a year in the
Peruvian Andes it's a tree planting
ceremony attended by over 200 men women
and children from various villages in
the area once the festivities are over
they begin their hike up the mountain
carrying shovels and other tools and
provisions with them plus infants and
the saplings even the llamas come along
their two-hour Trek takes them to an
altitude of over 4,000 meters above sea
level
they follow ancient paths once used by
their ancestors the Incas lived in
harmony with their environment for
today's population the idea is to give
back what they've taken from nature the
past few centuries have seen the area
almost completely deforested with no
effort to replenish the devastated
Woodlands these people are the first
generation to recognize that something
has to change
Aramaki onus one of the village elders
is here with his family I mean it's hard
to dig holes in the ground here you
might dislodge rocks you can never rule
out accidents you have to be extremely
careful
our work on parity burns Minear our
Wallace Lukas Tommy there are no trees
left here and no firewood together me
they are their lean another so I'm glad
that we're planting new trees my friends
and neighbors have all come along to
help
yeah um Randall Constantino uh Luka is
the man behind the project he set up an
NGO called the Association for Andean
ecosystems or a : in 2001 he and his
team want to plant twenty five thousand
saplings today they have to work quickly
so that the roots won't dry out if
there's no vegetation or trees the water
will flow straight from the mountain
down into the valley and cause
landslides before it continues on to the
sea the new trees we're planting will
absorb the moisture that nature gives to
us mist and rain kumara pani trees are
the only way we have of storing the
water the tropical glaciers are the most
important source of water in the Andes
but global warming is causing them to
melt away at a growing pace entire
swaths of mountain terrain used to be
covered with polylepis trees a species
only found in South America it's highly
resilient and can withstand extreme
weather conditions at night temperatures
here can drop to minus 20 degrees
Celsius in both the winter and summer
the trees at these high altitudes
therefore grow very slowly over the last
19 years the biologists from the NGO
have been observing changes in the local
climate madras thorn as people who come
here expect to see huge forests with
tall trees blocking out the Sun what
they don't appreciate is that we're four
thousand four hundred meters above sea
level
places the tree line is as low as 3500
meters but here it's different and I
will hit as you like I see more woodland
means more liquid in the overall water
cycle the hope is that eventually this
would enable the glaciers to reverse
their retreat what my recipe does here
what not anymore you'll burn as
precipitation when it rains the tree is
ensure that the water doesn't simply
disappear instead it's stored by the
trees roots and by the moss that grows
everywhere otherwise it would evaporate
far more quickly especially when the
sun's shining carried away on the wind
no CFA cement a developer tiempo it's no
killer man in the slower the water makes
its way down from the mountains the
longer it remains available in the
villages in the valley all year round
normally this would be the wet season
but rainfall has decreased something the
villages are all too aware of the
reforestation project includes the tree
nurseries managed by local people in MO
Hannes village the saplings are nurtured
for 12 months until they're sturdy
enough to be planted their survival rate
has now reached almost 90% echo1 pays
the villagers money for the trees the
Association itself is funded by private
donations
some of the tree nurseries are now
getting their own greenhouses in order
to provide better protection for the
plants and that also means new job
opportunities this kind of work is hard
to get so it's a sound opportunity for
us not just for me as a technical
specialist but also for my younger
colleagues logistically they need a lot
of people attend a CSA necesita
logistically masterfulness
and that also applies to the tree
planting enterprise which involves
villagers from many local communities
they're committed to the project even if
its fruits will only be enjoyed by the
generations to come
[Music]